when I'm facing a big decision I make
sure I do three things
scientists studying the brain have seen
that all decisions big or small consume
the same amount of energy so when you
need to make really important decisions
be vigilant about not wasting energy on
decisions that aren't going to make a
massive difference to your life
your brain needs fuel to think just as
much as your body does to move if you're
very hungry neurotransmitters can't be
produced compromising your ability to
think and make good decisions so when
you need to make an important decision
make sure you're not hungry
the final step is to stop the fear of
loss dominating your decision making
an objective friend can help you
identify the best decision because
they're not weighed down by the fear of
what could be lost in the end the
decision is always yours but it helps to
seek this kind of advice